Гаетон Мазо ще у школі вирішив працювати сам на себе.
Тому разом зі своїми друзями відкрив оригінальний бізнес: реставрує старі кросівки.
Попри те, що клієнтів вистачає, прибутки поки мізерні. Усе – через величезні соціальні відрахування.
Проблема – гігантські соціальні стягнення та податки.
Це божевілля! Після того, як я сплачую всі відрахування з 10 тисяч євро прибутку наприкінці місяця нам залишається лише три тисячі.
Ще одна велика проблема – наймані працівники.
Французьке законодавство  настільки сильно їх захищає, що звільнити когось роботодавцям фактично нереально.
Власник м'ясної крамниці Саша Міло знає це з власного досвіду. Він не раз програвав у судах.
Це так, ніби я одружений з усіма цими людьми.
Ти вже навіки приречений до цих відносин. Щоразу маєш платити величезні відступні і дбати про їхню перекваліфікацію.
Для дрібного підприємця це непідйомний тягар.
Такі закони свого часу проштовхнули профспілки і не збираються іти на поступки.
Жодному з останніх французьких президентів не вдалося реформувати ринок праці – усі спроби закінчувалися масштабними страйками. Тепер це зробити прагне Макрон.
Макрон хоче, щоб великі підприємства в майбутньому не були зобов'язані декларувати свої прибутки за кордоном.
Але тоді вони переведуть туди також доходи зі своїх французьких філіалів.
Далі скажуть, що у Франції у них збитки, тому вони змушені скоротити працівників.
І тоді в людей навіть не буде можливості оскаржити це в суді.
Утім, економісти переконані, що Макрон на правильному шляху.
Склалася така собі подвійна система: багато старших людей надійно захищені постійними договорами, а переважна більшість молодих змушені працювати на тимчасових договорах.
Це несправедливо, адже без постійного договору у Франції не можна ані житло отримати, ані кредит у банку взяти.
Гаетон не хоче здаватися.
Йому подобається його справа.
Молодий, амбітний та працьовитий – Гаетон є уособленням нової Франції, за яку виступає президент Макрон.